je proposais une cause ou casting
candide je n'ai pas la réponse à partir
de combien de followers ont commencé à
monnayer son instagram sait pas nager
il existe des zones d des entreprises où
il existe les nanos influenceurs les
micros influenceurs et après tu as les
tops influenceurs donc ça peut commencer
à partir de 1000 jusqu'à 10000 ensuite
de 10000 jusqu'à 30000 et après tu peux
être un grand accord donc ouais ouais
c'est le cas le plus haut taux de
l'acaps agacement face à gap
voilà c'est ça puisqu'on bien touché par
des coups agathe ouais c'est ça c'est
entre cat et 6000 euros par mois mais
pourquoi vous venez dans l'émission la
carte
sert à quoi les gens doivent halluciné
follower sur turin star pas énormément
je suis 100 mille un peu un peu moins
bien par mois s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît parce qu'on ne sortirait pas
énormément je fais beaucoup de postes
pour cent en gagner d'argent quoi c'est
pas bon de sortie c'est parce que tu
travailles avec des marques exactement
quand même la moitié région fait pas
voilà je vous le dis s'en fait pas oui
merci que sous les dents juste parce que
même vous n'avez pas rempli et 6
millions sur twitter
nous on a beaucoup d'abonnés convention
qui ont peu d'abonnés mais qui vit qui
ont un vrai impact sur les jeunes ça n'a
rien à voir avec aucun impact non je dis
pas ça mais peut-être que si c'est
l'effet la pub pour beaucoup de gens que
vous êtes forcément crème glacée comme
c'est pas parce que vous avez des petits
jeux vous voyez ma vie